what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we got ourselves a trailer
for The none dose John how are you I am
very excited I'm feeling spiritual today
how are you sir
doing yeah all righty well guys hey
leave a like on this video I'm excited
to see what they have in store for the
expansion of this Conjuring franchise
speaking of which I wanted to give a
heads up that uh our other rejects Roxy
stryer and Tara Erickson I'm going to be
having them do a reaction to The
Conjuring the first movie they both have
never seen it that'll be going up on
this channel hopefully by next week they
just take a little bit of time to edit
so uh yeah keep a lookout for that guys
anywho let's swing into action
oh
wrong with the school
something doesn't feel right
something's wrong with this guy
he's at school Oh I thought she's a girl
what happened oh she's back sister
there's something here
that's not meant to be
I like
she might have said girl I don't know
what did you see
oh it's all right there
what are you doing
I got it really bad
this demon was once an angel
dude God damn right she was rejected by
God
[Music]
nuns it wants that power back storm read
it's okay to be scared
I'm scared too
you send that thing back to hell
she just wants to read the magazines
yeah
read them for the Articles cool
whoa
pretty neat
oh nice
nicely done I was pleasantly surprised
by that trailer yeah same the first one
I thought was a lot of people treated
like it was this horrendous disaster I
liked it overall it was fun I thought it
was like fun it was definitely bottom
cheer The Conjuring franchise but it was
fun and it also led to one of our
coolest real reject experiences where we
got to go to Mexico and that's where we
actually got to be dead meat James it
was a great time but this I feel like we
could be potentially Landing ourselves
in an animal create Edible Creation is
the second one right and an Annabelle
creation situation where yeah we had the
first one here which was like and then
this is the follow-up they now they have
the opportunity to really improve upon
that and this one trailer alone I
thought was very effective like it had a
lot of atmosphere those little bone
chilling uh the performances look really
strong it had a better sense of mood and
Dread a lot of the cool visuals and
scares and she actually looks like she's
got a hardening back a little bit more
to her original design and Conjuring too
a tad bit and I can't really lay out the
exact distinct differences but it kind
of looks that way to me yeah I'm I'm
looking forward to it I'm surprised by
how like I actually looked really good
it didn't look as like cheesy as I
thought it would be they actually didn't
even look cheesy to me it looked
effective and what's stormbreak doing in
all these horror movies she is she the
one of our new scream queens that we got
going on no we need as many like caliber
actors as we can get G but yeah no I
absolutely agree and I think you know
there's there's definitely a trend among
these movies and these Conjuring movies
of really coming back and making that
sequel hit if the first one didn't you
know I mean the first one obviously made
huge amounts of money and it was a movie
that I too was like yeah I enjoyed the
vibe the atmosphere it's just like
pretty straightforward run in the middle
when it comes the actual story so I
think they've got a lot to improve on
here but a lot to also draw upon from
that and I think you know people
especially in the United States are very
engrossed by and susceptible to
religious forms of horror so I feel like
you know something overtly uh you know
religious engine based or at least
centered in that world of nuns and the
clergy is I don't know it's a really
effective thing to get under people's
skin and as one of these movies goes
this looks like it has that good amount
of vibe and Aura and atmosphere and then
it's just about watching how creative
they can get with the jump scares and
stuff I think this is the director of uh
the the curse of La Llorona oh okay a
couple other things so too do The
Conjuring three yes the devil made me do
it so you know definitely uh no stranger
to this franchise and I hope that this
is his best installment yet I love how
James Juan just chose this guy to be
like the main successor to The Conjuring
franchise out of nowhere it's kind of
surprising this feels like something
that has a better cinematography too
like every shot here if you just skim
the trailer it's actually like really
effective visuals throughout and a lot
of kids being endangered like the last
one I have a very small recollection
would actually went down to that movie
but it's more like adult based right and
this feels more youth-based yeah you had
you know like the the nuns in training
and stuff like that you had like you
know people in their teens I remember
but not so much like children and I feel
like that's another thing that the cert
the certainly The Conjuring movies I
think uh kind of bring to the tables
there's always like a family element or
there are always children involved and
there's something uniquely creepy about
horror surrounding and involving and
stemming from children yeah and two this
is a period piece still so like I think
that's got an innate charm about it that
these Conjuring movies as a whole tend
to bring well also the other thing I
just realized as well is that The
Conjuring movies are the only ones where
you have
um the the Warrens and you know they
have characters that continue on yeah
um other than if you count like
Annabelle 3 which focused on which was a
good movie but if you have like
Annabelle 3 which it focused on uh the
the daughter of the war yeah like this
is the first spin-off where they're
taking the lead from the former previous
spin-off yeah and you're actually having
them uh starred in the sequel as well
it's the Farmiga franchise boy I feel
like it would be really cool if uh
somehow even though there's a big
difference here in Arizona when this
takes place yeah it's that big of a
difference it's kind of big right what
is this this is like these Tyson can't
just like transition into
re-aging technology unless they do time
travel yes they go hey maybe she can get
sucked into some kind of Rift in space
and time through hell to the present
yeah there's something there they can do
but it's just magazine gag I know that's
clever when the photos all create the
none another thing too I think is just
as a trailer as well the first trailer
rode so much of its Good Will off of
that one jump scare I remember that
trailer saying stay till the end and
then they and they do have a very
effective wonderful jump scare at the
very end in so much of the excitement
was based off of this one good jump
scare that the trailer had and here it's
really pitching the whole package you
know yeah like I see the views on this
trailer are not that great so the
initial excitement may not be that
ramped up right now but I feel like good
word of mouth and maybe even just good
word of mouth I'm like hey this trailer
is actually good I do some alrighty guys
well thank you so much for being here
what did you think about the none 2
trailer were you surprised by it being
better looking than the first one what
are your nitpicks leave them down below
uh be sure to leave a like subscribe
people look out for that Conjuring
reaction but before we head out let's
end this with the pain
aniso liver Anisa if there's one person
here who is likely to become an evil
haunting nun I think it would definitely
be you let's face facts John has made a
lot of promises to you about specific
spots where he would meet up with you
things that he would do with you due to
you you know what I mean and yet uh he
has not fulfilled any of those
obligations it has been years in the
making and then you probably are feeling
a lot of resentment feeling scorned and
hurt by the man who you put a lot of
faith in and would do a lot of good for
you so naturally you would become
someone who becomes celibent and then
find yourself working within the you
know the hierarchy of the Catholic
Church eventually finding your way into
becoming a demon-possessed none because
you try you thought finding God would
allow you to you know forgive John but
then instead it just harbored more
resentment that eventually consumed your
whole soul and now you're after John and
you want to kill him uh which I support
and then I will Place him with another
white guy maybe Michael B
you guys don't know Michael Eva Omni
media uh Denise thanks so much for being
here and uh I I feel like this one went
well
foreign